[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Sébastien Chenu bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes députés du
Nord vice-président de l'Assemblée
nationale et porte-parole du
rassemblement national et on est
ensemble pendant un peu plus de 20
minutes on va commencer évidemment par
se remaniement vous avez vu le nouveau
gouvernement borne II c'est le
gouvernement d'action qui a promis
Emmanuel Macron pour vous un
gouvernement sans aucun changement dont
la ligne politique apparaît très faible
très interrogative je vous donne
quelques exemples on ne comprend pas
bien les ministres qui sont allés au
suffrage universel et qui ont été battus
ne sont pas repris mais il y a ceux qui
ne sont pas allés au suffrage universel
comme Eric Dupont-Moretti et qui eux
reste alors qu'ils se sont un peu
défilés ils s'étaient annoncé et
finalement ils se sont dit je me
présente pas finalement ça leur permet
de rester on a des ministres qui sont
sortis pour des histoires diverses et
variées je pense à Damien bad mais on en
a d'autres encore Dupont-Moretti ou
Gérald de Darmanin qui demeure alors
qu'ils ont un certain nombre d'histoires
qui ressemblent un peu à celle de Damien
Abad pour en tout cas pour géra
permanent ou en tous les cas d'une
enquête ouverte sur Dupont-Moretti bref
on comprend rien si ce n'est pas
la justice c'est déjà prononcée il y a
des gens qui ont des
dossiers qui ne sont pas traités de la
même façon mais surtout on a le
sentiment que le Président de la
République n'a pas entendu ce que les
Français voulaient lui dire quand le
ministre de l'Intérieur et renouvelé
après le fiasco du Stade de France cette
année rien comprendre lorsque
l'outre-mer a voté a envoyé un message
clair au moment des présidentielles et
des législatives et bien l'outre-mer est
sanctionné puisque le ministère de
l'Outre-mer est rétrogradé je pense que
les élus d'outre-mer le vivent
d'ailleurs très Malestroit
je pense que pour nos compatriés
d'outre-mer et pour les problématiques
qu'il rencontre il était important
évidemment d'afficher cette priorité le
fait
il a été donc rétrogradé par rapport à
Madame brun Pivet qui occupait cette
fonction on comprend plus rien à canaux
il y a un vrai flottement moi je trouve
dans ce dans la construction de ce
gouvernement et dans la politique qui
est menée il y a toujours pas de ligne
directrice on fait revenir des sortants
des ministres qui avaient été remerciés
en effet revenir parce que visiblement
il y a un problème de recrutement il y a
un problème de renouvellement il y a pas
grand monde qui se bousculent pour être
ministre d'Emmanuel Macron et puis moi
je disais en fait pour être ministre
d'Emmanuel Macron si vous êtes un homme
qui a trahi son parti et qui est techno
vous serez promus ou vous pourrez entrer
au gouvernement mais alors si vous êtes
une femme si vous êtes quelqu'un de
fidèle à son mouvement politique c'est
voilà c'est c'est quand même très
porteur
on voit bien qu'elles ont été assez
maltraitées dans ce dans la construction
de ce gouvernement un irritant que
majoritairement de poste de secrétaire
d'État tout ça est très bancal et en
fait ces bancales comme la politique que
men Emmanuel Macron c'est bancal comme
la vision qui Emmanuel Macron de notre
pays puisque ce n'est plus là en même
temps c'est n'importe quoi on va revenir
évidemment sur sur les textes mais pas
juste sur ce gouvernement puisque vous
parliez de Damien abaque d'Amiens Badie
il aurait pas dû quitter ce gouvernement
ou Emmanuel Macron a eu raison Elisabeth
band ont eu raison de de le faire partir
visiblement le feu au lac c'est-à-dire
que le gouvernement et Damien bad se
sont mis dans cette situation Damien bad
avait visiblement ses difficultés ces
procès ou en tous les cas ces dossiers
ils le savaient il a eu tort d'accepter
alors une plaindre il a eu tort
d'accepter de prendre des
responsabilités parce qu'ils se
retrouvaient au milieu du gué face à un
tiers de barrage de la presse chaque
jour il fallait pas prendre ça fallait
pas assumer ce type de responsabilité
lorsqu'on sait qu'on va être confronté à
ce type de difficulté le gouvernement a
été maladroit en le nom et maladroit
évidemment en levant ça fait un effet
absolument
de justice n'a été prise contre Damien
bad ou est-ce que il a eu raison très
difficile mais moi je suis attaché à la
présomption d'innocence qui ne doit pas
être remplacé par une présomption de
culpabilité c'est la présomption
d'innocence qui permet
Eric Dupond-Moretti d'être aujourd'hui
ministre à Madame zakiropouloud d'être
aujourd'hui secrétaire d'État qui a
permis à Gérald de Darmanin de continuer
à être ministre c'est la présomption
d'innocence
quand le dossier avait été ouvert il
avait eu cette présomption d'innocence
et c'était bien normal et aujourd'hui la
justice s'est prononcée mais ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'il y a des
traitements visiblement différenciés
selon les individus et je pense
qu'Elizabeth borne ouvre une porte assez
dangereuse où on fait au cas par cas
presque à la gueule du client en
fonction du dossier de la façon dont il
est traité médiatiquement et je pense
que ceci n'est pas tenable la
présomption d'innocence elle est valable
évidemment pour les politiques elle est
valable pour tous les citoyens demain si
dans une entreprise dans un média on
véhicule un certain nombre de rumeurs
sur les uns et sur les autres et qu'on
demande aux gens de quitter leur
fonction la vie n'est plus tenable c'est
pareil dans une entreprise c'est pareil
dans une usine
un mot juste sur la suite du casting
Olivier Véran qui était minis chargé des
relations avec le Parlement et qui part
après quelques semaines seulement à ce
poste quel signal on voyait au
parlementaire et bien là je dois dire
que c'est peut-être la seule source de
satisfaction alors évidemment le grand
public n'est pas j'allais dire le plus à
même peut-être d'apprécier la relation
peut avoir un ministre de la relation
avec le Parlement et les parlementaires
mais enfin l'idée Véran c'était le plus
mauvais casting possible pour les
relations avec le Parlement c'est un
ministre basta ministre qui considère
d'ailleurs en opposition président de la
République que les députés de la France
insoumise et du rassemblement national
ne sont pas républicains c'est un
ministre qui moi par exemple
le président de la République lui il
parle des parties du gouvernement et
l'arc républicain il va du PC wellr pour
le président de la
républiquement il parle pas de partie de
gens qui sont dans l'arc républicain
nous sommes tous séduits de la même
façon et je pense que le Président de la
République là-dessus le conçoit de façon
tout à fait sincère mais Olivier Véran
était ce ministre qui refusait de saluer
les députés du rassemblement national ce
ministre qui s'est d'ailleurs en
première conférence des présidents à
bredouiller quelques mots lorsque Marine
Le Pen lui a demandé s'il considérait
les députés du rassemblement national
comme les autres il a beau douillé il
savait pas bien où il en était bref il
était pas à sa place pour gérer les
relations avec le Parlement Olivier
Véran c'est quand même quelqu'un qui
s'est assis plusieurs fois sur les
libertés aussi des Français qui a
cherché à les réduire lorsqu'il est
ministre de la santé c'est quelqu'un qui
a une conception du débat démocratique
en limitant leur liberté personnelle on
l'a vu pendant tous les débats c'est
quelqu'un qui a une conception très
restrictive de ce qu'est la République
oui d'accord
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas la hauteur
de vue c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas la
distance c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas la
retenue Olivier Véran au fond de
lui-même il est resté un vieux militant
socialiste sectaire donc aujourd'hui il
est porte-parole du gouvernement très
bien il ira nous raconter chaque jour
que le gouvernement fait très bien son
boulot il sera très bien faire ça il est
très fossil avec le président de la
République et le Premier ministre il ira
portait la bonne parole matin midi et
soir pour les relations avec le
Parlement nous nous félicitons que
Franck Riester qui est un homme de
retenu qui est un homme qui considère
ses collègues avec de la même façon
quelque soit leurs étiquettes politiques
arrivent là c'est beaucoup plus simple
pour pouvoir travailler ces relations
j'ai pas de raison de lui faire un
procès d'intention Olivier Véran
il parle du gouvernement mais
[Musique]
et Emmanuel Macron hier en ouverture du
Conseil des ministres il a déploré
l'absence de volonté de partie du
gouvernement de participer un accord de
gouvernement dans sa bouche on imagine
que c'est pas vous les parties le
gouvernement qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de cette phrase mais là-dessus nous
n'allions pas évidemment participer à un
gouvernement alors que nous le
combattons nous combattons la politique
menée par Emmanuel Macron parce qu'on
n'a aucun sens nous nous sommes au style
à la retraite à 65 ans nous nous
souhaitons aller bien plus loin sur le
pouvoir d'achat des Français
mais les Français nous nous sommes à
partie de gouvernement nous nous
considérons et les Français nous l'ont
dit en rassemblant 42% des voix Marine
Le Pen aux élections présidentielles et
en faisant entrer 89 députés les
Français ont dit qu'ils attendaient de
nous que nous assumions des
responsabilités responsabilités que nous
assumerons dans un avenir plus ou moins
proche c'est une évidence vous pourriez
voter des textes issus de la majorité
mais vous savez pendant 5 ans nos
députés ça c'est pas beaucoup vu parce
que nous n'étions que 7 ils ont voté des
textes des amendements des propositions
de loi et maintenant de tous les autres
bords politiques quand on pensait que ça
allait dans le bon sens on n'est pas des
gens sectaires l'inverse n'a jamais été
vrai aucun député des républicains aucun
député de la France insoumise aucun
député en marche n'a voté une
proposition de loi un amendement une
proposition faite par un député du
rassemblement national nous nous ne
sommes pas des gens sectaires quand ça
va dans le sens de l'intérêt des
Français de l'intérêt de la nation nous
sommes toujours au rendez-vous
d'ailleurs à ce propos
présidente du groupe renaissance du
groupe la majorité présidentielle au à
l'Assemblée nationale était invité du
Grand Jury dimanche à l'as dit qu'elle
n'ira pas s'asseoir à la table de Marine
Le Pen ou de Mathilde panot pour
négocier je n'irai pas chercher leur
voix je n'irai pas chercher leur vote
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça et
c'est leur problème vous savez nous on
se détermine pas en fonction des
histoires de bidouillage nous on a un
câble qui est clair nous sommes
l'opposition à Emmanuel Macron 89
députés le plus important groupe
d'opposition à l'Assemblée nationale
nous sommes l'opposition nous allons
donc nous opposer à ce que nous
considérons comme une politique brutale
ou alors dans le sens de la
déconstruction du pays mais nous allons
à chaque fois proposer c'est important
d'expliquer aux Français qui est pas
qu'un chemin pendant des années on nous
a fait croire qu'il y avait qu'une
politique qui était possible contre le
chômage une politique libérale il y a un
autre chemin qui est possible à chaque
fois on proposera et en cela on est très
différent des autres la France insoumise
on le voit eux ils veulent tout casser
tout renverser mais en fait c'est
toujours le fantasme du grand soir on
veut casser déposer d'émotions de
censure tout mettre par terre mais nous
on n'est pas missionné par nos électeurs
pour ça on est là pour défendre des
idées des propositions on en a deux là
qu'on vient de mettre sur la table
d'abord on a demandé une commission
d'enquête sur la hausse des prix sur
l'inflation parce qu'on considère que ça
c'est une problématique précise concrète
qu'attendent les Français et puis la
réintégration des soignants qui ont été
virés d'ailleurs par Olivier Véran de
leur poste parce qu'ils étaient non
vaccinés là aussi c'est du concret c'est
rien de vouloir casser les institutions
alors qu'on peut peut-être faire avancer
les choses mais comment vous allez faire
avancer parce que vous allez faire des
propositions de loi bon mais si personne
veut de les voter ça veut dire que c'est
5 ans de mandature du rassemblement
national finalement ils vont servir à
rien non d'abord vous savez qu'il y a
c'est un peu de la technique
parlementaire il y a aussi des niches
parlementaires donc on verra
bien sûr mais on verra qui se détermine
sur la réintégration des soignants et
sous quel avec quel motif ça je pense
que c'est intéressant et puis il va y
avoir des discussions budgétaires on
verra jusqu'où on peut pousser les
choses sur le pouvoir d'achat est-ce que
le gouvernement est prêt à faire des
gestes s'il veut passer son budget il va
falloir qu'il fasse des gestes il va
falloir qu'ils changent de braquet il va
falloir qu'il s'ouvre à la discussion je
pense qu'ils ne peuvent plus ils ne sont
plus en capacité de gérer les choses
comme ils l'ont géré pendant 5 ans de
façon parfaitement dogmatique et
sectaire il va falloir qu'ils acceptent
que l'opposition fasse des propositions
j'ai sur le pouvoir d'achat puisque ça
va être l'un des premiers textes après
le texte covid est-ce que vous avez des
lignes rouges Olivier Marleix qui est le
président de le groupe à l'air il a
écrit alizabeth borne avec les trois
priorités Dr et lignes rouges est-ce que
vous vous avez des lignes rouges est-ce
que si certains points ne sont pas dans
le texte ne le voterai pas mais tout est
possible aujourd'hui nous on attend de
voir ce texte qui va être présenté après
demain ou demain pardon en conseil des
ministres jeudi pardon après-demain en
conseiller des ministres nous nous avons
qu'elles sont nos priorités nous
souhaitons la TVA à 5,5 sur les énergies
nous souhaitons 0% de TVA tant qu'il y a
de l'inflation sur des produits de
première nécessité on va aller très on
va monter très fortement sur ces sujets
là et on va voir ce que le gouvernement
nous propose si le gouvernement propose
des gadgets des mesures qui ne sont pas
pérennes des scotchs sur des jambes de
bois il faudra pas compter sur nous ça
veut dire qu'il y a pas arrivé à 5-5 sur
les produits de l'énergie il y aura pas
de vote du rassemblement national on va
voir ce que le gouvernement est capable
d'entendre à chaque fois qu'on pourra
flécher de l'argent rendre de l'argent
dans la poche des Français on sera au
rendez-vous on pourra compter sur nous à
chaque fois que ce sera du gadget à
chaque fois que ce ne sera pas des
dispositions pérennes à chaque fois que
le gouvernement essaiera de nous enfumer
vous ne comptez pas sur nous pour les
collectivités que vous allez porter oui
parce qu'en fait on a vu que la hausse
du point d'indice pour les
fonctionnaires que nous appelions de nos
vœux qui est nécessaire le scandale
c'était de ne pas l'avoir fait depuis 10
ans il ne faut pas qu'elle repose sur
les finances des collectivités sinon ça
veut dire quoi toutes les communes moi
j'ai beaucoup de communes dans ma
circonscription qui ont déjà du mal à
pouvoir abonder des subventions aux
associations au CCAS etc mais toutes ces
communes vont devoir faire des efforts
inimaginable elles le font déjà avec le
la hausse des prix de l'énergie une
commune je crois comme Hénin-Beaumont me
disait c'est 800.000 euros par an donc
les communaisons des difficultés il faut
que ce soit le budget de l'État qui
prennent en charge cette hausse des
fonctionnaires
demain il y aura le temps fort
évidemment au Parlement la déclaration
politique générale d'elisabethorn qui ne
sera pas suivi dans votre confiance à
l'Assemblée nationale vous le regrettez
moi je pense que ça aurait été une bonne
manière en fait à l'Assemblée nationale
en tous les cas au Parlement de pouvoir
se soumettre à la confiance elle n'y
était pas obligée madame borne alors ça
va pas changer fondamentalement les
choses d'autres premiers ministres ne
l'ont pas fait avant elle de toute façon
nous nous n'étions pas prêts à voter la
confiance donc nous quelques 70 cours
vous ne l'auriez pas votre mais nous
n'avons pas confiance dans ce
gouvernement on n'aurait pas voté la
confiance à c'est une évidence donc on
aurait pu s'abstenir il y a une motion
de censure ensuite qui est déposée par
l'extrême gauche là encore c'est formal
commencer on va attendre de savoir ce
que Madame raconte et puis on se
déterminera ensuite mais je pense que
vous pourriez déposer une notion bien
sûr voici le rassemblement
on n'arrive pas dans une institution
pour commencer par tout casser et
vouloir destituer un gouvernement parce
que remplacer madame borne par quelqu'un
par Madame bornbis ça n'a aucun intérêt
donc on va prendre acte de ce qu'elle
raconte on va voir jusqu'où nous on peut
faire monter nos propositions et c'est
comme ça qu'on se définit une opposition
qui s'oppose mais qui construit qui
construit aussi pour l'avenir parce que
c'est là que les Français vont
comprendre ce que les députés du
rassemblement national peuvent apporter
toutes ces pierres que nous allons poser
ici là et sont destinés à démontrer ce
que nous ferions si nous étions à faire
mais ça veut dire pour vous c'est pas
une erreur le fait qu'elle se soumette
pas de vote de confiance et c'est pas un
signal de faiblesse politique c'est une
faiblesse politique elle a appris
qu'elle aurait du mal à rassembler une
majorité elle ne le fait pas on s'en
remettra très bien mais la France
insoumise qui dépose une notion de
censure là vous dites le faire avant
même le discours de police général ça
c'est pas une ça c'est une erreur la
France est un ministre l'extrême gauche
est parti dans une radicalisation de ces
discours qui ne respectent même plus ce
qu'est la République c'est-à-dire que on
les voit leur approche du Parlement est
totalement anti républicaine il se
comporte très mal ils veulent tout
casser ils veulent transformer
l'Assemblée nationale en ZAD en squat
tout ceci n'est pas en forme pour le
moment ne pas serrer la main de ses
collègues ne pas respecter le
l'institution dans laquelle on est ce
comporter très mal comme Madame Rousseau
disait on fera du chahut à chaque fois
que je me suis abattre prendra la parole
ça c'est par républicain les vous savez
quand on est dans ces assemblées c'est
pareil pour le Sénat on est tous élus de
la même façon
représente tous le peuple à égalité donc
mal se comporter c'est mal respecté les
Français mais nous on est là parce que
les Français l'ont souhaité mais on
respecte les institutions on les
respecte vis-à-vis de ceux qui nous ont
précédés on les respecte vis-à-vis de
ceux qui travaillent et on les respecte
parce que nous portons la voie de
millions de Français qui nous disent
battez-vous vous savez moi les Français
que j'ai rencontrés encore ce weekend
dans la circonscription j'étais à
Escaudain dimanche par exemple me disent
sur le terrain proposer battez-vous pour
faire avancer ce en quoi nous croyons
cherche pas ce qu'on casse une machine
ou est-ce qu'on bloque une institution
ce qui s'est passé à la commission des
finances le vote du président de la
commission des finances ou le
rassemblement national n'a pas obtenu
des voies autres que les vôtres c'est à
dire qu'il y a pas eu d'alliance entre
la droite et le rassemblement national
pour bloquer
ericoquerel est-ce que ça montre quand
même que vous restez un parti avec
lequel on peut pas passer d'accord donc
parce que je pense qu'il y a eu des
vice-présidents de l'Assemblée et j'en
suis l'exemple avec ma collègue allait
la porte qui ont été élu avec les voix
d'autres députés donc ça veut dire que
il est possible que des députés du
rassemblement national soit élu et
désignés par leur père sur certaines
responsabilités mais là on a vu les
républicains flancher préféré faire
élire un homme d'extrême gauche il va
falloir qu'il explique aussi à leurs
électeurs eux qui pendant toute l'année
nous serinent en disant nous sommes les
experts en matière économiques nous
sommes les défenseurs du monde de
l'entreprise des PME des TPE bon il
préfère faire élire un homme d'extrême
gauche
islamo-gauchiste
d'une gauche radicale
anti PME antitpe ils ont fait ce choix
maintenant il faut l'assumer je crois
que c'est politique parfois amène à de
drôles de choses ben là on en a eu
l'exemple il y avait Jean-Philippe
Tanguy un homme diplômé un homme
compétent un parfait républicain qui
vient de la droite gaulliste qui se
proposait pour gérer de façon impartiale
cette commission des finances ils ont
préféré les laisser passer un homme qui
brandit la menace d'utiliser cette
commission des finances pour faire des
chasses aux sorcières
nous avons plus de députés nous sommes
l'opposition nous avons gagné ces
élections et je pense que c'est le nœud
gordien de tout cela c'est que les
républicains mais comme les socialistes
j'écoutais monsieur Assouline avant ils
ont du mal à valler la pilule ils n'ont
pas compris qu'ils ont perdu ces
élections et que le monde de demain se
dessinera sans eux en tous les cas sans
eux
ils ont quand même plus de 60 députés là
ne sont plus des ne sont plus en
capacité d'être des des alternatives de
pouvoir ce ne sont plus eux qui demain
représenteront l'alternative pourquoi
parce qu'ils sont dans des ambiguïtés
ils ont une jambe chez Macron une jambe
dans l'opposition
ne sont plus une alternative à Emmanuel
Macron et je pense que il leur faut
ouvrir les yeux sur cette réalité bon
vous venez de l'UMP ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous leur tendez pas la
main à la droite vous ne pourriez pas
leur temps de la main mais nous nous
tendons la main à la droite à la gauche
à tous les gens qui viennent mais pas au
parti politique en tant que tel est
parti politique elle a l'air le PS le PC
sont des vieux instruments verrouillés
au service de leur propre intérêts mais
bien sûr à leurs électeurs vous savez
moi je suis le premier député depuis
1958 dans ma circonscription à ne pas
être de gauche officiellement dans cette
circonscription j'ai donc été élu par
des électeurs qui probablement à
d'autres moments de leur vie politique
ou à d'autres scrutin vote aussi pour
des gens de gauche il y a aucun problème
avec ça moi je suis le député de tout le
monde et mes collègues par exemple dans
d'autres départements étaient élus
probablement par des gens qui toute leur
vie ont voté à droite nous on a dépassé
depuis longtemps ce qu'est la gauche et
ce qu'elle à droite les Français ont
dépassé ça depuis assez longtemps aussi
puisqu'on permet juste de la commission
des finances est-ce qu'Eric Coquerel
peut se maintenir la synthèse à sa tête
alors qu'une plante a été déposée contre
lui forcément c'est encore vous savez
nous on a des principes et ils sont
valables pour nos adversaires politiques
moi je n'ai aucune espèce de aucun
espèce de tropisme ou d'inclinaison pour
Éric Coquerel ses méthodes sa façon
d'agir je considère qu'il a une
présomption d'innocence en revanche
concernant ce qui lui reprochait d'après
ce que je comprends c'est d'avoir
draguer un peu lourdement une militante
France insoumise j'entends d'ailleurs
qu'il faille évidemment préserver
accueillir la parole de femmes victimes
de choses graves de harcèlement de
propos ou de gestes déplacés ça ça n'est
pas négociable mais j'entends aussi que
la politique ne se baptise pas sur des
rumeurs donc aujourd'hui Eric Coquerel
et je le regrette a été élu grâce à la
complicité des républicains la tête de
cette commission des finances
et on ne va pas construire ou demander
aux élus de démissionner dès qu'une
rumeur surgit donc c'est trop où sur des
histoires qui ont 10 ou 12 ans au niveau
de la plainte une plainte sur des
affaires qui ont dit sur 12 ans et comme
une sorte de calendrier qui interroge
aussi
à l'automne a priori avec une bataille
qui s'annonce entre Jordan Bardella et
Louis Aliot quel est le meilleur profil
pour succès à Marine Le Pen d'abord une
bataille le mont est grand personne ne
s'est déclaré aujourd'hui comme étant
candidat à la présence du rassemblement
mais les deux ont de la légitimité les
deux sont d'excellents camarades et moi
je pense que à chaque fois on nous a
fait le reproche de dire bah oui il y a
toujours que Marine Le Pen qui est
candidate à ses succession s'il y en a
deux cette fois-ci et bien ça montrera
que notre mouvement politique est
capable aussi de gérer plusieurs
candidatures pour ce poste de président
mais j'ai beaucoup de considérations et
pour l'un et pour l'autre ils sont très
différents ce qui les réunissent
non c'est sûr mais ils sont tous les
deux sur la même ligne politique on
attendra qu'il se détermine mais c'est
vraiment la même ligne
les différences générationnelles
d'approches de méthodes bien sûr qu'il y
a des différences
plus vers ce qui était le Front national
que lui à Lyon qui est plus sur une
populaire au Front national avant Jordan
Bardella ce sont deux excellents
camarades ils ont tous les deux
légitimités à pouvoir incarner notre
famille politique moi sincèrement j'ai
de l'affection et la considération et
pour l'un et pour l'autre et on saura
gérer les choses
merci ça va s'enchaîner d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin
[Musique]